Okay,
we are
live here.
I'm going to try to clear my mind of um
distractions today
software and game development.
And we get to do
Restream.
Okay.
I don't know why I have the stupid
Acrobat on here. Let's just remove that.
Good.
Pause this preview.
All right. So, the plan for today
Right. So, where we left this off, we
had done some initial refactors.
We had fixed to a large part uh the
speed drops
and we had this stable to I believe
16ish levels.
We definitely wanted to solve 15 levels
in time. Um but ideally it should be
like 16 17.
And then what we're going to do is we're
going to continue refactoring.
The code is a total mess for this.
Really, if all we do today is we get the
code into a spot that I'm like
moderately happy with and that we can
run core experiments on, that is enough.
That will be enough for today.
A little bit unstable still, but it is
16 levels solved.
Yeah, there you go.
All right.
Okay. Right. So, we were messing with
the roll out loops.
right. So, it's this is the original
pryo stuff and then from here
Not too bad. It's only about 600 actual
lines of stuff to think about.
I'll do that while I read it.
Okay, so we still have a bunch of
[ __ ] RNG and seeding stuff.
Is this sane enough that I can actually
just go through it and understand what
the hell's happening?
it. It's either already or it's almost
there.
Let me see if I can figure it out. So
curriculum start And
I still can't figure out what the [ __ ]
going on here. It's like too much crap.
I'm basically just finding little
snippets where it's like, well, this is
obviously scary, but the rest of it is
just like generically bad.
two wheel inverted pendulum at a pogo
jump.
Okay.
Yeah, I told um I told Cash roughly the
thing that was wrong with continuous
that I hadn't had time to get to yet.
And then I know the guy in the discord
who has been working on sweeps.
Yeah, it's a small fix. I don't actually
know if that was the full fix though.
I have a whole bunch of PRs to merge.
I'm aware
this needs to get done first.
Okay, let me actually think about this
first principles here. I need to know
whether I need to decide whether the
goal should be that we start curriculum
M and we roll them out for at most
Horizon
or we continue to roll them out until
episode end
or And
hey, Dino,
your thing. Yeah, I know this setup is
um it's meant to be very very easy if
you have um any sort of local Nvidia
GPU.
Um I know it's a bit more of a pain with
C I should probably add more dedicated
instructions for not that. It's just we
really haven't made the process of setup
on CPU machine good. Um well it's the
setup is easy but just like a lot of the
stuff is requires GPU to run.
You pretty much can just run the torch
fall back which is super slow.
move this here.
Um,
5 will solve nur actually no Finn. So
the problem with neural MMO like the
problem with curriculum stuff is it gets
way worse with many agent ends because
you need states that you would need
states that are good for all the agents.
I think if we were to make like a
version of neural MMO 3 that were fast
single agent um and then like mix in
some more some M's with more agents we
could do it but just throwing it on the
current config no
I'm trying to think if we want this to
go all the way to the end or
Well, no. There's going to be a failure
condition, right?
a few puzzles
Rubik's cube in under a minute. 3
minutes similar Kenny Cush new 5.
Which version of 50 are you using? Are
you using the like um the simple CL
branch? That should be the algorithm
that actually works.
Uh, I wouldn't think that you would need
this for a Rubik's cube though.
Like the 40 defaults are very strong.
M that don't have an end. Yeah. So, I'm
just trying to think of counter examples
to where um you know that would suggest
one way or the other the way the
algorithm should work.
I wonder if it works without the tail
improvement thing.
Tetris is infinite. Oh, that's a good
one, Jess. Um,
algorithm turnout. So far the algorithm
is doing amazingly
and I'm just the thing is that all the
code sucks. So I'm having to clean up a
lot of stuff and I have to run a few
ablations to see like if we need some of
the bells and whistles that are making
it even longer.
Well, yeah. I think Jess um
I mean I think regardless of what you're
doing like Jax is just bad [ __ ] It's so
bad.
I obviously I can't speak to it cuz we
we have a completely different type of
infra problem.
But from what I've seen, Jax is just so
[ __ ] miserable. like, oh,
they [ __ ] too.
This
It's getting to be nonobvious to me that
this is a reasonable
I've started it this way. So now I have
to finish it this way. But
It's fine. We'll just do it. We'll just
do it. And I'm going to be careful.
We'll just accept that the next couple
weeks of this are going to just be
[ __ ] miserable.
Um,
we have the one other algorithmic thing
to experiment with as well.
It would be very very weird to me if
this were not how it worked.
If this matches, it matches. If it
doesn't, we go back.
Oh, wait. Let's watch.
Hang on.
You have to be sure. But I'm pretty sure
it's broken.
We'll restore this and then we'll ablate
the tail improvement code entirely.
All right, we'll ablate the tail
improvement thing. And then if that if
that doesn't work, then we'll know that
we basically have the algorithm the way
it needs to be and we just have to
simplify it and make it faster.
Make sure this works.
And then we will ablate the uh the tail.
Moose crafting solar panels.
That's an AI. That's very cool.
cuz technically possible.
It's possible though unlikely that this
thing doesn't matter.
We don't expect this one to work. If it
does work, that'll be very interesting.
Hello, Liberty.
Salvaging Clank. Absolutely [ __ ]
miserable.
I think after this update, there's going
to be some time spent re-evaluating.
Like, in my mind, it's actually no
longer clear whether these like code
models are actually even net useful.
I I'm starting to think it's very likely
that they've just been optimized like
they're optimized to make you feel very
productive, but even like no matter what
you do, no matter how you're using them,
you're actually just [ __ ] around
wasting time.
This is getting increasingly likely in
my mind.
move to a low level.
But things are easier low level, not
harder.
Unironically, the models would probably
be better if you just deleted JavaScript
from the training that
I'm going to do three seeds here.
This is quick.
We'll double check to make sure the seed
is being applied. Give it a second
though.
Okay, it's not. I'm just dumb.
It's supposed to be seed.
At least it's At least we know it's
deterministic though.
12.
Okay, now I have to run another seed.
13.
I need to know how much how much seed
instability there is in this. I think
there's quite a bit.
Yeah. So, it just did it wrong. See,
man, this is the tough thing. It's like
it'll just do the experiment wrong.
It seems like tail replacement is a
small but substantial improvement.
It's not actually clearly better though,
is it?
I'm trying to think if it's better or
not.
Oh, actually no, it is
cuz if you just have a very long
timeout, for instance,
like let's say you just put a very long
timeout on the same end.
Continuing will screw it up, won't it?
All right. I actually do think this is
probably better to do it with resets per
horizon.
right, we're going to try a couple seeds
on this.
See if we get anything remotely
reasonable. Last time it [ __ ] up the
experiment
by breaking our terminals. Thank you
very much for that. PhD level
intelligence, by the way.
Um,
not looking too good, but we'll see.
Maybe this is fine.
I'm leaning very heavily towards
resetting on terminals. I mean,
resetting on segment being the correct
thing to do algorithmically as well. I
think you get too far off of the um
uh the collected good trajectory
otherwise.
It doesn't seem like the experiment is
agreeing with me. We'll see. No, it's
better than before already.
And remember, there's a lot of seed
variants, so we have to run a few seeds.
But if it gets stuck at eight or nine,
then it's just Bad.
Where's 40 baseline get on this end? I
think I saw it get like
11 10 or 11 after two billion steps was
the best I saw.
Oh, and that was I should be clear
that's with a massive model. So this is
we're constraining it to test with a 50k
perm Puddle.
as usual.
Rightest.
This is a very cool game. This is
actually like the perfect type of game
as well to test state sets on. It's a
whole bunch of vaguely related but like
quite different puzzles.
It's like the ideal possible end first
eight sets.
We just take the data and clean up the
code.
We just say okay all the pieces are
basically needed.
it's not um there are no pieces that we
can trivially remove,
which is the level of experiment that we
wanted for now. Let's double check that
this is good and then we will continue
refactoring.
I have to slightly change the way I
think about the algorithm as a result,
but that's not a big deal.
Yeah, that puzzle end is very
interesting to me. You guys see why this
end would be like this game would be
very cool um for this algorithm, right?
It's like a bunch of unrelated puzzles
stuck together.
Continual learning in some sense as well
would be solved by um this approach.
So it kind of solves it by defeating the
point of it, which is fine.
This is so annoying.
This we may genuinely need.
Yeah, because we can't we can't have the
sizes be um compile time, right?
Yeah, we don't want the sizees compile
time.
Yeah. So this is a lot of freeze. Um
actually this is a good question, right?
So
if we were to use like I can implement
an allocator in like 10 lines, right?
And I actually have it for other stuff.
Uh I'm pretty sure it does screw up your
address sanitizer, doesn't it?
Like if I were to do all of these in one
mal, we lose a dress sanitizer across
the boundaries, don't we?
You got When you say you got it to work,
like how do you get it to work? Right.
Because now you have you fundamentally
have one big segment of memory.
So you're not checking for out of bounds
rights between the individual sections,
right? Or am I misunderstanding?
Cuz we actually we do have allocators
for like weights and stuff.
This I'm not sure about yet. I think
generally first of all we just need to
have fewer fields.
You poison the 100 bytes and unpoison.
No, no, no. But like let's say that you
allocate 10 bytes
and then you allocate another 10 bytes,
right?
And then you try to write into the first
buffer, but you accidentally end up
writing into the second buffer.
That's like a very easy thing to do,
right?
You have red zones.
That's kind of gross though, isn't it?
And then you're also assuming that the
out- of-bounds right will be in the red
zone.
So if you jump over it, you're also
screwed.
This is how Malik right now with asan
works, is it?
Well, I know it's not magic, but I would
assume it's just tracking like it knows
the exact am like you don't need red
zones, do you? You literally just check
whether the right is outside of the
allocated memory for the specific
pointer,
Like that's not how I would have
expected it to have been implemented.
Still, it doesn't seem like it's
worthwhile to be re-implementing chunks
of an address sanitizer for um the
purpose of saving a few freeze.
but like this is all so this is on
program close. Like these are allocated
on program at start and then they're
freed on program close. And also this is
just too many things. Like um I think we
can just reduce the amount of crap that
we're tracking in the first place.
Let's see what we're looking at.
We got memory.h
Okay. But the fundamental thing here,
right, is I'm not
I could see this being useful with
dynamic stuff potentially,
right? Because this is
I could see this being useful for
dynamic stuff, but like it literally is.
We're just allocating memory up front
and then we're freeing it at the program
close. It's that simple.
We have zero dynamic memory like we have
zero dynamic memory allocations.
If you're defining dynamic to be after
in it,
I suppose.
Yeah. Yeah. You are mal you are
malicking once here. Well, no, you still
can need arenas or areas. Is it arenas
or areas? Arenas, whatever.
Um, I'll show you.
Okay. So, right here,
we do this for all of our tensors.
So, we do this for all of our tensors
here where you register the shape of
your tensor
and then once you've registered all the
shapes, it allocates them all at once.
So then if we look at like source
models,
you see I was actually pretty happy with
the way that I did this.
All right. Look at this. So you like
Alec, you just register the shape here.
You register your activations like this
and you give it the pointer
and now it knows the shape
and then when you've registered
everything then you allocate it all at
once.
It's kind of nice.
No, you're good. I mean, sometimes I do
wonder if there's a simpler way to do
some of these things, but a lot of the
times it's like introducing more
concepts and things just makes it worse,
you know?
I mean there are easier things if you
wanted like you know you could allocate
just uh you could just make an array of
pointers and then free all the pointers
in the array like there are many things
you could technically
I actually don't like like the free all
the pointers in the array thing. I do
find that that like that makes it harder
when you inevitably when you screw
something up to track the errors back.
I think in this case the dumb thing is
the best thing.
Let's see what else we can fix. So, this
stuff at the bottom is from um from
Puffer 4.
And we really don't have that much stuff
to figure out, right? It's like
500ish lines. And now we actually know
that all the different chunks of the
algorithm are needed.
So now I just have to figure out whether
or not there's anything that's
completely dumb here.
Okay. Don't look to add structure before
you understand existing structure.
There.
Hello cash. This is the continuous PR.
Does this actually fix it for uh for
your env?
I can probably just insta merge if you
need this.
It's funny that it actually kind of
worked even with it.
Yeah, I can merge this. And then I have
to make sure that this actually gets
into um
gets into puffer five as well.
It's funny because I'm like I'm almost
positive this is not the full fix.
But that is a good fix to have and that
is tested enough to take. So thank you.
And we need to do more basic science on
[ __ ] like this. I just need to get the
final algorithm done for RL.
Um, and then we just need to like polish
in numeric. Polish in numeric.
basic numeric smoke text and slowly burn
down.
Yeah. So, I guess the problem at the
moment, man, is the algorithm is not
fully done.
Like, I think that there are two
unsolved problems in the field that we
need to finish. This right here should
solve one of them. What I'm working on
right now.
And the price is going to be about 600
lines of kind of messy code
until I clean it up more.
And then there's one other thing that we
can try that I think will likewise be
another 500ish lines.
And I think at that point like we should
be we should be able to solve problems
that we clearly could not solve before
to the point that there shouldn't really
be any just like dumb examples left
where we should clearly solve the
problem and What?
That's a nice diff.
I mean, that's a nice looking diff right
there.
We'll see if it makes sense.
Lovely.
Here, let's just write a massive regax.
Okay. So, it's not really improving the
length, but the individual code looks
way cleaner. You see?
Yeah, they're not a million pointer
accesses
Okay. It saves a little bit of code, but
then mostly it cleans up a lot of lines.
We'll run this. I'm going to run like
five seeds.
We're going to do this the um RNG
changes.
the RNG changes like that'll save a
bunch of lines and I think then maybe
I'll be able to actually look at more of
All right,
we got our first seed.
We're going to just run five seeds of
this manually.
because last time we had the RNG
changes, it was kind of wacky
and I want to make sure if we're going
to change the bitwise determinism or the
bitwise solution on the default seed
that we're really not messing it up. I'd
like to also find at least one seed that
also gives the 16 back.
Just so we know it's there.
My hope is basically that we cleaned up
the data structures a little bit. So
like before the individual lines of code
weren't even readable. There were a
million redundant pointer accesses that
just made it a mess. Now it should be a
little bit better, but the RNG is a
total mess. So, we'll have this cleaned
up. Um, I want to get to the point where
it's like the code is at least clean
enough for me to be able to see all the
stupid defensive programming crap that
it does and like fix that and then the
code will hopefully be short enough that
I can see any remaining core
architecture issues. But like crap, it's
just such a process to get it into an
even like a state where you can do
anything with it. It's just so bad.
Okay, at least it is actually pretty
consistent here.
I really want to run five seeds. Yeah, I
need to run five seeds. I really should.
We're going to be responsible even if it
takes a few extra minutes. We'll run
five seeds.
I just want to see if it like ever gets
12 or anything so we'll have like a
really clear difference.
I think we the goal for today should be
that we have it running a sweep,
albeit it'll have to be a very slow
sweep, but um because we only have one
GPU to throw it at, but uh I want to run
a sweep on 2048
hopefully end of day.
If we sold to 2048 with this
like by a good margin, I think then it's
like 99%
like Good.
The other thing I want to do is also
much easier to check.
17.
So 17 is in there. Purely seed RNG. So
that's very nice to know.
It did like this really janky RNG crap
um that I just do not want in my
codebase. It's going to change the It's
going to change the exact solutions
here. So, we're going to have to um just
in case, we're going to have to rerun
some seeds.
Let's start looking at this in the
meantime instead of just scrolling X
like in imbecile.
Okay, there's still a few extra
variables in here, but this is way
better than it used to be.
The register is way better.
These allocations are no longer like
completely disgusting. The names are
disgusting, but we can fix that easily.
These guards are disgusting, but we
actually already know what we're going
to get rid. Like, we already know how to
fix this.
These helpers are gross. Some of them
are going to get deleted by the random
change, the RNG change.
Uh so actually this is reasonable man.
So the reason for this is we have
circular [ __ ] between this and
pufferlib.cu.
Um ultimately what's going to happen is
the entire curriculum is just going to
get pasted into pufferlib.cu and then
this file goes away. The for source will
just stay in a file and we won't have to
deal with guarding [ __ ] Either that
or we'll re we'll split it up back in a
way where um we no longer have this
issue.
I'm actually I'm undecided. If there's a
clean way to split it with no guards and
no extra code, I might keep the
curriculum stuff separate. We will see.
I don't know how much it makes sense to
do that.
I'm not sure yet.
Well, do you have a sim tore real
inverted pendulum?
I'm starting it. Well, point it out
whatever you want, but 50 code isn't
stable yet.
So, you might want to just do four and
then like, you know,
um merge it and then like push it back
up to five once we're done.
Um the new state stuff changes envi a
little bit and then it also is going to
add
6 700 lines worth of code changes
probably on uh the training
Still makes a [ __ ] mess, doesn't it?
Be better.
Make sure it doesn't break determinism.
And we'll run five more seeds.
I get an extra bagel today
because
the cut has gone a little bit too far
and I no longer have any bloody energy.
I'm down I think 8 pounds or something
for the summer.
when I'm back in Maryland
after the summer.
It occurs me that to me this would be a
good time for me to take a minute to go
grab vitamins.
I'm going to kick off the next one, go
make my um my drink, and then I'm going
to um kick off the last one.
We got a 16 out of it.
Three 14s.
Nine stars from 6K.
You want to start the puffer? Start the
puffer.
good weekend. Yeah, I'm honestly I'm
needing a lot of time off with this type
of work. Um, having so much stuff
through Codeex just [ __ ] sucks. I
hate it. I really truly hate this. I'm
just I'm getting absolutely zero
enjoyment whatsoever out of my work the
last few weeks, which kind of just
sucks.
My hope is that we're going to just like
push through
We're going to finish the new algorithm.
We're going to get some nice results
from testing. And then I'm pretty much
just going to have like, all right,
let's think about the business a little
bit. Let's like figure out how we can
clean up the code so it's not so much of
a disaster with these stupid [ __ ]
coding agents
and get the code base into a state that
we can actually trust it for doing
really hard stuff, you know?
I mean, I actually I don't mind it for
certain things, but like
it just shouldn't be touching the code
base like this.
you know, if it's going to go off like
if there's stuff where you can verify
positive outcomes, for instance, like,
hey, go find a bunch of tricks to like
improve the speed of stuff and then like
report them
and then let me decide how to actually
implement them. Stuff like that maybe.
I don't think it has no use, but [ __ ]
you know, you even the exact advertised
use for it is terrible.
I'm just trying to see. It's like, can I
figure this one out yet? Yes. No. Maybe.
Ah, okay. Now, there is an annoying bit
here.
Yeah. Yeah, there is an annoying bit
here. Hang on. I understand why this is
such a mess. Is there another one of
these lower down
or is it just one?
Uh, no. Here it's uh No, this is CPU me
copy. This is fine.
And this is CPU. Okay. So, this is
because of
Yeah, we still didn't figure this crap
out, did we?
All right. We have to figure out
we got to figure out the state sets,
right?
What do you guys think about just having
the API basically be reset and then it
can take an optional state?
So we wouldn't have to have a dedicated
compute obs function. And we could leave
it a detailed to the environment. And we
also when we set the state, we wouldn't
have to do any recomputation of anything
because it would just be like the reset
function would just be reset to state.
I think that's clean.
before the before the first forge of the
next roll But
I still think it's cleaner this way.
You have to clear buffers. There's a lot
of details like that to handle arch
Is there any advantage to using a
statectruct?
Uh yes, Arch, if you just if everything
that needs to be reset is in the state,
then you literally just do like end of
state equals this new state and it's
done uh very efficiently. Hi.
Something's got to change with the whole
GPU market [ __ ] I'm just going to
assume that it can't be the case that
these things just keep going up in price
forever for the same hardware.
Um,
I mean, if it is, we can like directly
just thank the LLM companies for
stalling progress in science.
I'm trying to think how hard the other
thing I wanted to do is now. See the
other thing I wanted to do is very
simple.
Well, it depends if we confuse the
colonel or not, doesn't it? We'll see.
I suppose we will see
It's like fighting a water balloon. Like
you just remove [ __ ] in one spot and
you get [ __ ] somewhere else.
It really is.
that is so worth it though to get rid of
this.
That's really worth it. We get rid of
stupid API function that nobody asked
for.
We get rid of stupid additional GPU copy
operation.
Yeah, basically 750 lines of this
actually belong to the new stuff if
that.
No, it's less. It's like 700.
Okay.
I love how even when stuff that's like
it very obviously should result in code
deletion, I love when it still ends up
adding lines of code to the [ __ ]
project. It's just the best.
Only hope is at least that like it's
getting to be sane so I'll be able to
just delete crap that's obviously
redundant. But holy [ __ ] man.
It's not that the models degrade,
they're just [ __ ]
It just added so much crap.
I mean, this is ultimately on me for
just having done it this way.
I hate this. I hate this so [ __ ]
much.
Like I just don't understand. What the
[ __ ]
Wait, is this actually just going to do
what I think it's about to do?
I don't even know what to say, folks.
It's just like,
it's actually impressive how [ __ ]
convoluted this [ __ ] has been made for
no reason.
I guess it's ultimately like, yeah, this
is my fault for um
having prototyped the experiments this
way.
I thought it would be bad. I didn't
think it would be this bad. Like jeez,
man.
I love arguing with LLMs that the code
is crap for 15 minutes and then
eventually having it uncap the code.
the stupidest [ __ ] possible timeline.
I swear
I'm going to spend once we have the
algorithm stuff fully done, I'm going to
devote a very large chunk of time to
manual cleanups.
And by manual, I mean like you can't
even manually like this is not manually
editable. It's so [ __ ] Byzantine. I
don't even know what to do with this
crap.
Like manual, meaning get it into a state
where it is sane enough for me to
actually edit it myself and then do
that.
This is just awful.
At least I now know what needs to
happen. The process of fixing this
annoys the ever living [ __ ] out of me,
but at least I know what needs to
happen.
Also, it did it backwards. Um, one is
supposed to be error.
This is remarkably similar to like
asking a new programmer like questions
until they explain to you exactly why
their own code sucks and then fix it is
a really really really stupid workflow.
But whatever, we'll have the thing done.
Code will be in a state I can manually
edit. It eventually
it will be shorter. We'll have fixed a
bunch of [ __ ]
Will be fast. I can proceed.
Yes, exactly. Kvert, which is why this
is so frustrating.
Look at that. All this garbage is just
gone.
Okay,
we should train.
Which is 700 lines minus the other. So
670 linesish for Yes.
Look at that. 712 lines.
Basically just like identifying one
instance of shitty defensive programming
and being like, "Cool. Now remove the
other instances of shitty defensive
programming.
I don't know, convert. I think it's just
going to get to a point where we have
the core stuff for puffer done
and then it's just going to be like
improve the quality
and then um
hopefully things will be nicer then
I mean but even now like we can't I
can't just commit the current code
that's too much jank to have in the code
base longterm.
Now, this is getting close to the amount
of code I expected.
How much faster can we theoretically get
things? It's kind of hard to compute
that cuz it's like it's a complex job
with a bunch of memory management and
stuff or memory movement. It's not just
flops.
712 lines
minus this. And then there's one other
function. It is now
570 linesish.
Oh no, wait. Because this is also.
Let me set my title
or my category rather.
Hello, Anes
stream just crashed for no reason.
Should be good now.
It's not my internet. This was OBS. Like
the program just hard crashed.
Okay, I think
PR reviews this stream. Depends what PRs
if it's quick or not. I'm trying to
clean up the new algorithm. My goal for
today is to actually have this running
on um a held out end
because that will confirm whether the
algorithm is actually doing what it's
supposed to be doing. It works amazingly
on our dev ends.
Voice is echoing back.
Hang on.
Really?
Test.
Are you sure? Do you not have it open on
two tabs? Cuz I just tested. Can anybody
else confirm?
I just opened it on two t like I just
opened the preview of it and it wasn't
doing anything there.
Is my voice echoing? No echo.
Okay.
Two tabs.
I figured
it's all right.
Um,
we're good.
I think the one additional thing I need
to figure out,
there's still some [ __ ]
I'm not. No, we're not doing [ __ ]
mojo.
This needs
Why does this need vach?
U who did Gaussian. Uh I did. That's
actually um
I'm very interested in that. Oh,
actually was that was that the PR you
were asking about here?
Hang on. If so, it's a different name.
Oh, wait. Is this the same person? Hang
on.
is it the whoever this is with the Kirby
profile pick?
Is that um
Okay, that is your PR. Okay. Okay. So,
now I see. Cool. So, in that case, I'd
like to very much first of all thank you
for that because that's something we've
been wanting for a while. Um, I expect
that's probably a pretty chunky thing
for me to review while I'm in the middle
of this chunk of algo work. Yeah, pretty
chunky.
It's not terrible though if this is
okay. Full Gaussian process
across the board.
It looks like speed ups across the
board.
Uh worse train time, but way better
predict time.
Okay.
You basically have these exactly the
same.
Well, that's good. Let's see how much do
we have here.
So, presumably this is test harness
stuff.
The actual kernels here are quite
simple.
Nice.
Okay. Yeah, I'm gonna have to give this
thing a full review, but that's awesome
cuz Thank you. That saves me quite a bit
of time.
We'll see how the code is
this and okay, the rest is tests. Wait,
so it's 800 lines actually, right?
possibly less we get rid of the
prototypes.
I didn't even realize this thing has a
KD tree in it at all.
bindings for Python. Yeah, for the
tests, I'd assume, right? Cuz like the
thing is with this done, right? Like we
actually we're going to be able to port
we're probably not going to do it in
time for five, but like we'll probably
what I should mean is we'll keep the
Python bindings for five, but we can
just fully replace Python by six, right?
cuz that was the only hard thing to
port. The rest of the stuff that we're
using from Python is not essential at
No problem. I mean, that's the you've
done the the tough part of it.
We hand roll it. So, Arch, we're not
sure what we're going to do on CPU
support yet. I actually I do think CPU
support is important, so I will figure
out a nice way to do that at some point.
Um,
you have a CPU version. Very nice. Yeah,
the thing with simple kernels is like
CUD to C is basically C. It's usually
pretty easy to have a CPU version. Uh,
it would be nice if we could have a
better way to like share big chunks of
code between the two, but
that's a little tougher.
The low-level stuff isn't out of reach
at all. Just build some M's. You'll get
the gist of it.
Maybe download the Cbook PDF to read as
well.
You have both CPU and GPU on the repo.
Okay, solid.
Very solid.
Yeah. Okay. Cuz we don't want to add
like a second delay between um our
sweeps. Normally,
this is just moving stuff. So hopefully
this should not mess up. This is just
literally moving stuff from one file to
the other.
The C book PDF
is the first result, my guy.
I was tempted to open the that uh let me
Google that for you site, but I thought
that'd be a little too snarky.
So what this what's happening here? Let
me sort of explain. Um
so when I wrote VENV originally, I wrote
it with the assumption that we'd have to
compile veen with GCC
and then we'd have to compile training
uh with NVCC.
So there was this sort of barrier
between the C and the CUDA that was very
annoying. We do the whole thing under an
NVCC unit now.
So that means that we can basically take
all the big stuff out of veen and just
stick it into puffer
and then we can keep veend as a very
small little header file that is just C
and that's used by the ends
I had something really funny happen this
morning. I was just getting a breakfast
at my usual place and some guy came by
and said like, "Hey, are you Joseph
Suarez?" Like, "Oh, yeah. I know you
from Twitter."
That was pretty funny. Only in
California.
Allan is unfortunately um it looks like
the funding changes killed it.
That's funny.
I take basically like no pictures ever.
Okay. I think is this the same?
Yep. This is going to be the same.
Didn't actually move anything out, did
we?
Okay, so it made a mess. It's a
temporary mess.
Still a mess.
Seven without puffernet.h stage. I think
it was.
There you go.
That was the 6K.
Imitation learning on puffer
There is one project.
So, there's one project that does with
puffer. Um, it's more using IIEL for
like grounding than it is using it for
the actual like learning how to solve
the problem.
There's some applications where I could
see it being useful.
I don't think it would be particularly
difficult to add either. Like IL is
vastly simpler than RL
to set up. It's very very simple.
Well, you don't have the whole envelope,
right? which is the core thing that
makes the infrastructure hard.
Oh, I see. This is the restricted data
thing.
I really don't get the um American
fascination with France.
that shouldn't have been in the bindings
anyways.
confirm this
and we will see
2 p.m.
I got to leave myself at least what an
hour or so to get the run started.
I didn't hear anything about the uh
the Stamford setting, like the Stamford
stuff.
I will say already when I was at
Stanford, I was incredibly disappointed
by the um
the average student there.
I don't know what on earth's been going
on with Stanford. Like I don't have
context for any of this.
Okay, we do have we have 700 lines and
uh was itund and something of them?
Yeah, so 130 probably.
Yeah, we're still 570 lines. Okay,
this is still chunky for what it is
though.
Okay, I mean obviously like this stuff
could be inlined.
I don't like to air my any of my own
political views. I think um I like to
keep the focus of the stream on the
science and edge.
I think as a whole the most useful
neutral thing I could say about that is
that
um
I don't think it's inherently bad for
students to be engaging with politics.
The thing that is bad is when they're
doing so in an ideological echo chamber.
Like if there were actually some
substantial thought
um behind what students are doing, it'd
be a very different story. But
at least when I was there, most of the
students seemed incapable of basic
thought.
I mean, you had a bunch of idiots
blubbering their way through single
variable calculus.
It was pathetic.
Yeah, I think that it the thing that was
the most disappointing ultimately it
wasn't the specifics of like
it wasn't like the stuff that people was
saying. It was the obvious lack of
thought put into it.
Yeah, it's generally the case that like
the only place I have ever gone to,
right, and been like, "Oh, okay. Wow,
most of the people here are actually
genuinely smart."
Um,
actually I think it was two places to be
fair. The first time was I did a summer
program at Stanford where somehow the um
the like high school students that were
there ended up being way smarter than
the actual ones that got into Stanford
even though maybe like two of those
total actually got in. Um,
and then the other one was
at Open AI, but it's not the same OpenAI
as it is now, obviously, right? When it
was a much smaller place, much more
concentrated effort, most of the people
there were genuinely very good. And I
think that the Dota result is still by
far the best in the field.
Almost a decade later,
Hey, look at that.
666 lines,
530 lines, then
130 of other stuff.
That's good.
Good progress.
Presumably there's a free on this as
well, so maybe it's even shorter.
I'm trying to trim down some stuff. It
honestly, it made such a bloody mess.
Like way worse than I'd expected.
Who does stuff in puffer? It's basically
just C plus a little knowledge of how
GPU works. Yes, that's exactly what it
is. That's the [ __ ] point.
That's the point
entirely.
I thought it would be way scarier.
Exactly. It isn't.
It's only hard when you make a mess of
crap and introduce a bunch of [ __ ]
you don't actually need.
It's not that the problems are very hard
a lot of the time. It's that they're
being done in a way that's just
mindbogglingly idiotic.
All right, let's see what else we got in
here. So,
At this point, I'm honestly I'm just
refusing to work with trash code bases
anymore.
It's just a It's a complete waste of
life.
Like I honestly think that I'd find
working on like welding or something way
more fulfilling than um
doing engineering with morons.
Like there's something uniquely
torturous about working with bad code.
I think it's that it just it puts you
too close to people's idiocy. Like
normally when you talk to an idiot,
there's like a nor like there's a
barrier between the two of you where
they can go yap yap yap, but you don't
really have to care or like engage with
various parts of it. But then when you
have to deal with an idiot's code, all
of a sudden you have to like contort
your mind into whatever utterly stupid
frame of state that they were in, frame
of mind that they were in when writing
the thing and then try to like reverse
engineer from There.
Okay, this is kind of long but not
terrible.
We only have like three functions now,
right? Wait, let me see.
Of course it is, Arch. I've been doing
it for a while.
This is actually just about the amount
of code you'd expect now, right?
Way way way way better. Still need some
clean up, but like in my mind, this is
actually workable. This is just like
normal messy code. This is no longer
like absolutely awful, unusable,
unfollowable, horrible horseshit code,
right?
We get minus another 40,
which is lovely.
You can probably check um some PF things
soon.
took the file down from a thousand lines
to 600.
Go to sleep. Yeah, get some rest, man.
I uh I will review it. Expect it to take
a couple days, though. Like, I'm
finishing the current ALGO pass, and
there's one other potential ALGO thing I
want to do. This is like the core core
of the puffer update. Everything else is
easier for me to like go through and
merge once the core is done. So that's
what I'm finishing first. But then of
course all the PRs get merged in. This
is how it works every update.
I still have like a backlog of um perf
enhancements as well, like nice kernel
patches that some contributors have
submitted.
draft a paper this week. Best of luck
and get some rest.
Oh, wait. We already trained. We're
good. So
very small perf penalty.
is nice.
Suppose we should just do the uh same
training here with no curriculum.
See how it does
If this gives us the same
performance where all these args are not
getting respected. Good.
Well, this seems correct.
baseline does surprisingly well. I will
say
surprisingly well.
Still a very clear difference.
The government banned it
in Europe, right?
How do you onboard new members to the
project's repo?
Depends on level of experience.
There's just not a big repo, frankly.
Um, you build a couple M's, then you
know how to build M's. Congratulations.
Um, the whole training code is five sixk
lines.
That's pretty much the whole thing.
So we onboard people just by having like
a tenth of the code that you would
expect from a project this size.
It's like here, if you just look at the
source, that's all that's in here.
This is the C demo thing. This is
vectorzation.
This is the big file with the whole
training loop, you know. Here, does this
even do anything? I think this is just a
custom neural MMO net. Here's the
optimizer. It's 300 some odd lines. 900
lines for all the models.
Some extra shared kernels. The new
curriculum is only going to be like a
six. Well, actually some of this was
from the old stuff. So, this is only
like a 500 line edition. Here's
Kudnbinds if you need them. This is just
Python interop. And then this is Python
interop for CPU stuff. That's it.
It's removed for everyone until they
figure that out. Really
I mean they're not going to get any
sympathy for me from me. Like on one
hand, like I don't like the government
banning AI tech, but on the other hand,
they literally like went around like
lobbying the government, telling them
how dangerous the advanced models were
for years, and then surprise Pikachu.
Oh, we developed a super advanced and
super dangerous model.
It's like, are you imbeciles?
What math do I need to be become a good
AI researcher?
Um,
it really depends what you want to do.
Uh the thing that will be accessible to
you within the next couple of years is
basic multivariate derivative calculus
which is for the most part um a fairly
straightforward extension of single
variable derivative calculus.
You do need to be able to also have
matrices and stuff in uh in the
derivatives, but it really doesn't
change very much most of the time.
Yeah. Multivaried derivative calculus is
sort of the core of
modern deep learning.
You need both like some sort of
mathematical background but then more
practically you need actual experience
implementing stuff around it.
Um
yes, linear algebra, but not
particularly as it's taught in math
departments.
No, you should not rely on LMS for
studying math.
Just want to check that the end speed is
good
and that our baseline without CL works
correctly
Hey Spencer, we've got it down to I
think roughly 500 new lines. Um, plus a
bunch of refactors and stuff elsewhere
to make it fit nicely.
Uh, it's been absolutely no fun with the
way codeex is, but I've unfucked most of
the code.
It seems reasonably fast. I'm doing
final PF checks in a second, and then
I'm going to hopefully, the goal is to
get some experiments on 2048 running
today.
Uh, the tiny box I was using doesn't
work, so
I might just run it on Vast. We'll see.
I think I'll probably just do that.
The same settings. It's level 16 solves
with the um state set curriculum versus
10 without it
That's with heavy pryo as well. So
that's actually that's actually already
accounting for implicit prioritization
in the baseline
I think we can move this in
to a puff roll soon.
Now we can just move all this back into
Pop Pro.
who knows the game knows this is
hilariously false.
That's a thing.
Yeah, that's a thing.
Okay.
I forgot I'd done that.
We can fix this.
suppose this is something we should
probably test separate from um
we should probably test this one
separately
from everything else.
I don't know how I would have broken the
breakout benchmark.
That's the only thing I can think about,
right, is the advantage change.
once this is done it should be fairly
easy though to get it on to uh 2048 if
we have breakout matching the 40 bench
and we have our Our Soabon benchmark
still running.
should be fine.
I don't know what the heck this would
be.
Yeah, this is going to be way worse,
huh?
We'll try messing with the learning
rate. Next
Either that or we get breakout to work
with um
running advantage.
I mean, this clearly sucks. So, we'll
just ignore this.
See, this doesn't make sense. We have
the same model size.
It doesn't like the big learning rate
though, does it?
Definitely something screw with our
logs.
Um, you I don't think you can reverse
the emoji, so it would be swimming
backwards.
Is there a way? I There might be a way
to flip the character, actually,
but I think it's Unicode. I don't know
if it'll work well on most terms.
13.
I think for puffer five, the puffer fish
should just stream swim directly out of
your screen and then fly around in your
room. That would be the best.
Yeah, I figured, Jess, I don't know if
it's going to be like I I'm worried that
it'll just mess up your term completely
if you don't have full Unicode support.
instead of sim to real, it's puff to
room.
There's no way this [ __ ] works, right?
That's completely stupid, isn't it?
I'll try it for lols, but that's like
I don't know why the [ __ ] you would do
that.
So the reward clip plus scale I think
works There.
just reward clipping had to go back on.
But we'll have to figure that one
That's cool. I actually remember this
game.
It actually had like kind of cool It had
some cool ideas in it if I recall.
Wait, what? How did the How the [ __ ] did
we just do better than before?
going to sort this and then we're going
to go on to the 2048 stuff in a sec.
They're literally hacking around 32
bits. That's so funny.
It's got to just be a determinism
change, right?
Well,
whatever. We'll put the clipping back.
right. So, here's what we're going to
do. We're going to get um we're going to
get the next one set up.
Let's make sure uh 2048 actually
trains.
We're going to make one more probably
one more push.
invalid numb threads. Yep.
All right. We'll fix that in a second.
We'll just do like four and four or
whatever.
we're going to give this one four and
four.
Oh, I missed uh a message from Stone,
didn't I? I'm sure I was supposed to get
uh to meet up with them.
Let's see if we have any crazy ass
parameters in here.
Annoying, isn't it?
Yeah, we have some crazy ass params.
We got this. And now we just have to do
sweep.rain train dot
uh was it CL frack?
There
went
Nope.
Sadly not.
It does still work at um Okay,
interesting.
But like it's actually still good,
right? like 19 plus mil with curriculum
Come on.
Do you have your own puffer fish? Nope.
I like puffer fish, but I do not want to
take care of a puffer fish.
Need this. don't need.
Well, we'll get rid of it anyways in a
second
Yeah, we don't use expansion factor
anymore.
bro. Like, could you make the machine
learn?
You do that from having a hard time. We
do be learning some machines.
Or rather, the machines do be learning.
Get rid of stale stuff.
Still learning linear algebra.
Yes. Quite a lot left to do then.
I have a beginner's guide on my articles
tab on X
only mainly
excuse me mainly dedicated to
programming Okay.
Are you a British?
A British you say? No, that was
horrible. That wasn't even British at
all. Very much American, my friend.
trajectory max length is going to have
to change, isn't it?
There's one other thing I'm realizing we
have to What the Oh god. Okay, we have
to change some stuff.
I can probably figure this out off the
top of my head, can I?
If it's 1 KB, it's 32 MB
I have an hour and a half roughly
get this thing launched.
Two bytes. Okay, that's actually very
small.
Well, actually, we can know, right? So,
each merge is two.
I probably does need 32k.
Okay. Okay. So, we'll just set it to
512.
So, I'll just do every 32. And then
what's the 32K?
I think the initial reset takes a bit on
this.
Okay. 1.3 gigs, 1.4 gigs.
Fine to me.
I think we're uh we should be happy with
this, y'all.
I think we're happy with this.
Yeah.
So that ought to be a reasonably stable
version of the uh the new algorithm.
It's a very simple algorithm.
It adds only about 500 lines of code to
puffer.
I actually took the opportunity to clean
up some other bits that uh could have
been already.
Let me go grab
if I can get vast on here.
Okay,
we have vast.
Now, I wonder how this works.
Is it going to find me a different like
comparable machine to this one?
Your instance will not be able to start
until it could free again, which could
take hours to weeks.
You can copy your data directory to a
new running instance using
Wait, they've been charging me to store
this so that I can run it again when
this same machine happens to be free.
That's [ __ ] [ __ ]
Are you [ __ ] me?
That's a [ __ ] scam.
That's like
I was like, there's no way it's possibly
that [ __ ] dumb.
This looks good, right?
Six core
RAM somewhere.
Oh, wait. Wait. Why are they so cheap
all of a sudden? What?
Oh, this has [ __ ] internet.
This is good.
Xenon Platinum. [ __ ] that.
Uh,
kind of pricey.
But I think this is good, right?
Try this.
Oh, [ __ ] This has the xenons.
I didn't see it. I'm dumb.
Oh, no, no, no. I got it. It's fine. It
No, it's fine. We're good.
Yeah, we unfortunately need it for the
uh the docker.
Oh, no I don't.
Okay.
Option mark on hold.
Huh.
That's annoying. Well, this has to sink.
There we go. That was quick.
Uh, let's grab
Are you [ __ ] me?
[ __ ] condom man.
Okay, this works.
Very nice.
Okay.
2048 is that's why I got this box is
going to be to sweep 2048.
So see the thing is the soaban variant
that I'm working on is not a high
confidence end.
If it works on this sweep though with
248 we win.
All right, that matches. Actually, it's
funny. This matches exactly because it's
the same CUDA version and the same GPU.
So, this is bitwise deter like this is
bitwise consistent reproducibility
across machines. I'm pretty proud of
that.
Buffer is kind of cool sometimes.
So this is two.
Wait, what?
I think we can afford to do eight and
eight then.
We're sweeping.
Would deterministic sweeps be good?
Um, it would be pretty easy to have that
happen just automatically for you.
Uh, hang on.
separate branch
on the tiny puff.
You just like
clone the environment into a different
folder name. Just have another copy of
it for your stuff.
What do you need a VN for? You have the
same packages.
VNV is for like dog [ __ ] Python stuff
where everybody has different versions
of everything.
Oh, that's going to be so cool. If we
ditch Python, we can also ditch VMs.
That's going to be so nice.
That'd be so funny if we ended up like
also ditching UV. And it's like, hey,
the best tool in your stack was the
worst tool in our stack.
We're going to have to add credits to
this thing. Um, I need a way to
Is there a way to like get out of
T-Max?
Detach logs. Detach like gets me out of
um
like we can just do it this way. We'll
kill it and just
we'll just do this
here. We'll do this.
There.
Do it like this.
Now we have reasonable access to [ __ ]
Very good.
Let me go put some credits on this
thing.
nice.
We should be good for a while now.
And uh we
we basically got the thing done we
needed to get done for the day.
Let me think about what we can do.
We have the core algorithm for the most
part. Just needs testing.
I wouldn't mind seeing if we can set a
new speedrun record.
There's no real reason to think that it
should, but it would be cool if it
happened.
and then we'll see what the trajectory
lengths are.
going to need to be
a little longer than 16k, I think.
I don't really want to deal with this
being stupid right now.
We'll leave this alone.
I say we go for it.
This uh this will be fun.
So this is some
pork lineman,
huh?
Interesting.
Okay, that's why we're logging a billion
metrics.
I might even play this later tonight.
We'll see.
Yeah, we've got all of them except one.
Why is this one off?
Are we going to get the cards dying
thing again?
God damn it.
I did mess it up.
Well, good thing I caught it early.
And immediately we've got all new jobs
launched.
Okay. Hey bet. We're towards the end of
the stream here.
Is our first sweep running on Puffer 5?
There's one thing I wanted to still do.
something that should be
Let's see if this thing is still total
and utter crap.
Oh, a lot of it's on Boxabon as well.
Wait,
Ah,
it's actually mostly um
H.
Well, that's very nice, isn't it?
I think it's still worth keeping this
not merged into 50 yet because there's
some smaller things that um have changed
that I would like to evaluate. But this
is mergeable.
It's still net edition. It I'm adding an
entire new curriculum algorithm, man.
What do you expect?
And also um without the boxabon editions
which aren't going to get kept long term
that's like 500 lines less than 500
lines of code.
It's all in the curriculum file pretty
much.
Oh yeah and veen has not even been
cleaned up yet.
Like veen is a mess. This needs to still
get cleaned up. Okay. I'm feeling good
about this. Like we got it into a spot
where it's just normal messy. It's not
like un like complete and utter failure
crap.
Double check this experiment.
Much better. No f no failed jobs.
Good.
All right. So, this is fine.
Lots of people using puffer and help
stone.
Yeah, I should be chatting with him
actually. Thank you for reminding me. I
got to check my ex DMs.
Yeah. No, stone is quite good. Stone is
quite good.
Agent navigate higher dimensional
spaces.
I mean, that's kind of what the whole
optimization process does, right?
Well, I think we're allowed one stupid
thing, right?
Oh, wait. No, I have stuff running on
this.
Okay, we'll not actually implement the
stupid thing. I just want to look at
this.
I'm just checking cuz I'm just checking
if something is like if there's an
existing thing for this
I don't know if you can make it
efficient
Well, in this case, bet I have some
prior knowledge.
Oh, also, as everybody here started the
puffer, we're a few stars off of 6K
here.
It's um
eight stars remaining for 6K.
Yeah, bet. I think it's just going to be
continuous. I merged it because I had
basically the same fix. Um I told him
like the exact thing to fix if he wanted
to. Um, I have to go double check, but I
essentially I found a bug with
continuous actions and um, it's in a
client code repo at the moment that I
have to like go port over
Yes.
Yeah. So, I saw that and um I don't
think that was the entire issue, but he
gave me some pretty good plots for his
end, so like sure.
I wouldn't be surprised if he just like,
you know, with whatever LM he's using
was like, make sure it's a thorough
report that compares no per like sweep
curves before and after cuz otherwise
you're going to get me flamed.
decoupling.
Let me see what they did with this
thing.
You train against the laten, don't you?
how the original this is.
I don't like this paper for reference,
but it is an annoying base. It's like an
annoyingly decent baseline.
Hello, welcome. We're mostly finishing
up for the day. We have experiments
running.
This is an 8GPU box we're renting.
This is running our initial curriculum
sweeps on 2048.
And then we also have
um just a quick breakout
experiment going.
I'm just looking at a couple other
things in the meantime.
Yeah, we need two networks for this,
don't we?
You only need this at train time though,
right?
I think you only need this at training
time.
This is R&D. It's a very well-known
paper. I really don't like this line of
work.
It's a reasonable enough baseline for a
lot of things So,
It's still slow.
I guess we could try it though.
Yeah, we don't need to do the whole RNN,
I suppose.
It does need memory though. And no, it
does need memory.
I think that's basically everything I
can do for the day. Um, I got to get to
dinner soon anyways, so I'm going to do
that. Uh,
we have the experiments running.
We'll see if 2048 is the best end for
this.
I suppose if it isn't, we do terraform
or something.
We'll see.
Or even just doing so normally.
Little tricky that one actually. We will
see though. Anyways, well, thank you
very much folks for tuning in. Um, if
you want to support the project for
free, Star the Puffer on GitHub. Join
Discord to get involved.